we are asked what is the average rate of
change of the function f and this
function is f up here is the definition
of it over the interval from negative
two to three and it's a closed interval
because they put these brackets around
it instead of parentheses so that means
it includes both of these boundaries
pause this video and see if you can work
through that
all right now let's work through it
together so there's a couple of ways
that we can conceptualize average rate
of change of a function
one way to think about it is it's our
change in the value of our function
divided by our change in x or it's our
change in the value of our function per
x on average so you can view this change
in the value of function divided by your
change in x if you say that y is equal
to f of x you could also express it as
change in y
over
change in x on average how much does a
function change
per unit change in x on average and we
could do this with a table or we could
try to conceptualize it visually let's
just do this one with a table and then
we'll try to connect the dots a little
bit with the visual
so if we have x here and then if we have
y is equal to
f of x right over here when x is equal
to negative 2
what is y going to be equal to or what
is f of negative 2
let's see f of
so y is equal to f of negative 2 which
is going to be equal to negative eight
that's negative two to the third power
minus four times negative two so that's
minus negative eight so that's plus
eight that equals zero
and then when x is equal to three i'm
going to the right end of that interval
well now y is equal to f of 3 which is
equal to 27
3 to the third power minus 4 times 3
minus 12 which is equal to 15.
so what is our change in y
over our change in x
over this interval
well our y went from 0 to 15. so we have
a increase of 15 in y
and what was our change in x
well we went from negative 2 to positive
3 so we had a plus 5 change in x so our
change in x is plus 5. and so our
average rate of change of y with respect
to x or the rate of change of our
function with respect to x over the
interval is going to be equal to 3. if
you wanted to think about this visually
i could try to sketch this
so this is the x-axis the y-axis
and our function does something like
this
so at x equals negative two f of x is
zero
and then it goes up and then it comes
back down
and then it does something like this
it does something
like this and it does and was going
before this and so the interval that we
care about we're going from negative 2
to 3 which is right about there
so that's x equals negative 2 to x
equals 3. and so what we want to do at
the left end of the interval our
function is equal to 0. so we're at this
point
right over here i'll do this in a new
color we're at this point right over
there and at the right end of our
function
f of 3 is 15. so we are up here
someplace
let me connect the curve a little bit
we are
we're going to be up there and so when
we're thinking about the average rate of
change over this interval we're really
thinking about the slope of the line
that connects these two points so the
line that connects these two points
looks something
looks something like this and we're just
calculating what is our change in y
which is going to be this our change in
y and we see that the value of our
function increased by 15
divided by our change in x
so
this right over here
is our change in x which we see we went
from negative 2 to 3 that's going to be
equal to 5. so that's all we're doing
when we're thinking about the average
rate of change